صباح العربيه برنامج كل العرب من المحيط
الى الخليج اليوم نطل عليكم من مدينه ذات
خصوصيه مختلفه نطلع عليكم من بنغازي
الليبيه ثاني كبرى مدن ليبيا هذه المدينه
التي ما زالت اثار الحرب والدمار على
جدران مبانيها الا ان الحياه عادت ولو
تدريجيا بعد اربع سنوات من القضاء على
الارهابيين وتنظيم داعش الذي اعلن امارته
انطلاقا منها مفاده العربيه الى هناك
نادين خماش قلت له علينا بمباشر صباحي
[موسيقى]
من بنغازي تنضم الينا زميلتنا نادين خماس
طالعه عروس ليبيه اليوم يسعد صباحك نادين
من هون
يسعد هالصباح يا سهام
صباح العربيه ام مشاهدين قناه العربيه انا
متعوده يا سهام انت وفريق صباح العربيه
انه اغلبيه ايام هاي السنه ان كل صباح
نفطر مع بعض ونقضي اوقات حلوه في الصباح
انا ارتقيت انه حتى في ليبيا وحتى في
بنغازي عاصمه الشرقيه
وتتحدث سويا ونخرج سويا
بامتياز انا اليوم اطل عليكم في برنامج
صباح العربيه من وسط بنغازي في الشرق
الليبي هذا اللباس اللي انا عم بارتديه
بيسموه لباس شرقاوي بامتياز طبعا ليبيا
بلد كبير جدا وبلد متنوع فبالتالي يختلف
نوع اللباس شكله وحتى ايضا الطعام ولا
حاجات فانا طالما انا في المنطقه الشرقيه
فانا ارتقيت ان ارتدي اللباس الشرقاوي
بامتياز طبعا هذا اللباس سهام وكمان لكل
المشاهدين استغرق وقت طويل حتى نرتديه
يعني لي في هذه السهوله كما ترونه الان
يعني هو ترتدي العروسه كما وصفتني يا سهام
ايضا ترتديه السيدات في الافراح وفي
المناسبات هو لبس وزي تاريخي بامتياز يقوم
على مبدا التحذير يعني في اكثر من قطعه
ترتديه وكما تشاهدون ذهب يملا هذا اللباس
وكمان اذا شايفين انا راح اعمل كمان مثل
زميلتنا سهام هاي اسمها شو بتسموها انتم
المروحه
بس اهم شيء الريش اللي فيها انت اوكي هاي
سموها مروحه عندكم ههه
ههه هاي اسم مروه
عندكم وعن ناس ثانيين هواي هون في ليبيا
يسمون الشاشه باللغه العاميه يعني باللهجه
العامريه كم اخذ
الشاشه معروفه انه التوب او تحيه لفدوى
الجلال زميلتنا الليبيه والله يا سهام
بعرسها ضلت لابسه هالتبكي ساعه ساعتين
والله معها حق والف تحيه كمان لكل زملائنا
الليبيين ولكل الليبيين اللي عم بحضرونا
اليوم سواء في من غزه او في غالبيه المدن
الليبيه وايضا الليبيين في الخارج
حقيقه استغرق هذا اللباس
انا توقعت انه يستغرق وقت اقل يعني مثلا
في لباس تقليدي في بلدان مختلفه ممكن يكون
يعتمد على قطعه واحده فلا تستغرب يعني
اكثر من خمس عشر دقائق لبس لا هذا بده
يعني
اكثر من قطعه مع بعض وكمان انتم شايفين
هذا الذهب المختلف حتى الشعر والراس يعني
له طريقه مختلفه وكمان يا سهام بدي احكي
لك انه احنا حبينا انه كمان نفطر معك
شوف فطرتي بعيد عنك
شفت طرتي بعيد عنكم
سهام احنا هلا عم نشوف الفطور الليبي طبعا
يعني زي ما شرحت كل منطقه تختلف من جهه
لاخرى نحنا في المنطقه الشرقيه فطور
شرقاوي يعتمدون على الشكشوكه على العجه
وطبعا لننسى الشاي اللي به وشاي يعتمد على
الشاي مع حليب يتم خلطهم معا ومثل ما انتم
شايفين طبعا هو يعني البيض اساسي عنصر
اساسي في الفطور الليبي وهلا بنشوف احنا
كمان الشاي طبعا هو الشاي بالعاده بيكون
يقدم بشكل مختلف بكاسه مختلفه هلا احنا عم
بنصب شاي يا ريتك معي يا سهام ويا ريت كل
الفريق كمان معنا
هذا الشيف حليب وانا من محبي الشاي الحليب
انت تحبي الشايف حليب
يعني
يا ريتك معايا ان شاء الله المره الجايه
نعمل صباح العربيه